[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour les amis un petit tuto pour vous
expliquer comment bien utiliser un autre
test
et voilà
[Musique]
faites-vous vacciner vacciner
la liberté est la meilleure des
protections la liberté est la meilleure
des protections le chaos la pagaille
partout je n'ai pas une bannière de
combattre
vous m'emmerdez faites-vous vous
m'emmerdez faites-vous fasciner vous
vous m'emmerdez merde
[Musique]
en effet on vient de me diagnostiquer
une tumeur au poumon
une tumeur cancéreuse pas très
sympathique qui ne peut pas s'opérer
donc je dois rentrer dans un protocole
de six mois de chimiothérapie et de
rayons X ce qui fait que je suis désolé
portez vous bien et puis quand tout ça
sera réglé
on se retrouve je viendrai terminer ce
que j'ai commencé ce sera peut-être la
tournée des 61 au revoir